the health and safety of educators
remain a
top priority for the clark county
education association
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the request the teachers union
is making
during the next special session and what
may happen if those requests
are not met ccea demands the governor as
well as legislators protect
ccsd staff and put certain protocols in
place
you have to have new legislation tamiko
hopkins supports the teachers union
fighting for educators safety
the watson elementary school teacher
wants personal protective equipment
and workers compensation for anyone who
may get coveted while
on the job i don't think that's too much
to ask ccea making it a focus now upon
reopening schools
it's unknown when students will return
to a classroom but
educators can come to campus a concern
for the union considering the numbers
we have 229 cases right now
out of eighteen thousand educators that
have contracted the virus
twenty percent or ten percent of those
have been hospitalized
and that's been without being in the
schools in a statement the union
addresses two major issues
the first involves safety testing and
contact tracing
the union wants to require testing for
all ccsd employees
as well as ongoing testing throughout
the year the second includes employee
protection and
employer liability if there is no safety
program in place as i've spelled out
they should then have the right under
tort law to sue their employer
and if requests are not met we're going
to weigh our options we're
not going to encourage or allow an
educator to go back into these buildings
if they're not safe
when you say your options what are we
talking about everything's on the table
are we talking a strike possibly
i'm not i'm not addressing that right
now waiting for legislation before
taking
any action kristen drummond 8 news now
by the way the union's request coincides
with a business liability bill that's
going to be happening during this
special session
now ccea says it would make employers
free from liability regarding covet
exposure
if the business has been providing a
robust safety
testing and contact racing program the
union wants to add that kind of language
focusing on the school district